es ist Krieg und die Folgen dieses
Krieges kommen bei uns an das muss man
sehr deutlich sagen und insofern ist
übrigens wünschen das wollte am Anfang
niemals hören das Verständnis noch sie
leben in Leipzig sehr langer Zeit da wir
frieren müssen für diesen Krieg das
viele zumindest in Deutschland werden
frieren müssen in diesem Winter für
diesen kann nur darüber reden wie ich
mit Leuten das meine ich in dem Fall ist
sagt man so gern beim Bäcker oder beim
Metzger gibt's ja nicht mehr so viele
und ich hoffe es werden noch ein paar
kaputt gehen die glaubt man nichts mehr
und wenn ich hier das hohe Lied über
Robert Habeck den heiligen Robert höre
also dort höre ich nicht das Erzählte
reicht sondern das Erreichte zählt und
da ist bisschen nichts auf dem Konto
eingegangen die haben richtig große
sorgen welche eine Bäckerei lebt
ich kann das Brötchen nicht für 150
verkaufen weil da kein Mensch mehr kommt
das habe ich ja nicht erfunden die haben
einfach Angst dass sie die Energiekosten
nicht mehr zahlen können und das ist
nicht die einzige Sorge diese haben aber
das ist übrigens mit sehr großen
Programmen gegengesteuert worden ist und
die Herausforderung war ja auch das ist
unglaublich früher schneller hätte man
es machen ja ich würde mal
Sondervermögen das sind sonderschulden
ja natürlich das ist halt so das ist so
wenn man nach der großen comic-krise
jetzt in den griechischen Krise
Konjunkturprogramm für die AFD weil die
Leute wissen doch dass sie das
zurückzahlen müssen und die AFD kommt
mit sirenengeheulen und sagt müsste
alles zurückzahlen die machen eure
Zukunft kaputt eure Kinder müssen sich
und wir deswegen in Sachsen laufen den
die Leute nach ja und Putin ist
derjenige der will dass die AFD stärker
wird denn dieses Abschalten des Gases
ist ja genau auch
Krieg und das Verhältnis der Grünen zu
Waffenlieferung das vertiefen wir gleich
nach einer ganz kurzen Pause gleich
zurück hier bei
zurück bei wählt die richtigen Fragen
wir streiten heute über die Grünen und
das tun wir mit den Grünen und wir
streiten über deren Verhältnis zum Krieg
zu Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine Frau
Beck sie gehörten zu den
Gründungsmitgliedern der Grünen sind
eine der ersten Abgeordneten gewesen die
für die Grünen eben in den Bundestag
gezogen sind wenn wir wir sehen die
Bilder noch mal von damals wenn wir
dieser jungen Abgeordneten damals gesagt
hätten dass die Grünen für
Waffenlieferung für mehr Waffenlieferung
für Panzerlieferungen in die Ukraine
sind was wäre die Antwort gewesen das
hätte ich damals nicht für Möglichkeiten
weil ich tatsächlich den naiven Glauben
hatte dass keine Waffen einzusetzen
immer die beste Lösung ist ich bin heute
erschrocken über mich selber und frage
mich warum ich als Mensch aus
Deutschland wo der Nationalsozialismus
mit Hilfe von Waffen Niederungen werden
Ängste und mit vielen vielen Opfern
weshalb dieser Gedanke nicht in meinem
Kopf war und dass es eben hieß zu Recht
heißt nie wieder Krieg aber zu Recht
auch heißt Schutz der Opfer und das habe
ich dann in Bosnien verstanden und das
war
1993 Frau Beck die heute sagt sie findet
sich naiv im Rückblick Frau Fegebank
wenn Sie diese Lebensgeschichte von Frau
Beck hören sind sie heute noch naiv und
würden sie die Grünen heute noch als
Friedensaktivisten bezeichnen sicherlich
Friedensaktivisten aber ich finde das
sehr beeindruckend ich kenne die
Geschichte von Marie-Luise
Tränen nicht aber ich
habe unglaublich viel Respekt
vor dieser Entwicklung vor allem vor
dieser Erkenntnis
das gerade in der jetzigen Situation die
Waffenlieferungen
erforderlich notwendig sind
um den Opfern um denjenigen die
angegriffen wurden die Möglichkeit zu
geben sich zu verteidigen ihr
Territorium zu verteidigen ihre Familien
zu verteidigen ihr Leben zu verteidigen
und deshalb war für mich die
Entscheidung so hart das klingen mag die
war für mich sonnenklar zu sagen
natürlich müssen wir dem zustimmen nicht
nur dem Sondervermögen sondern auch
jetzt der Lieferung von schweren Waffen
die Grünen die so aus voller Überzeugung
jetzt für Waffenlieferungen streiten
gibt es keine Alternative da hat man aus
ihrer Sicht
im Moment glaube ich nicht weil der
Krieg ist so in vollem Gange dass der
nicht von heute auf morgen storniert
werden kann und besteht die Hoffnung ich
glaube aber dass wir da auch einer
gewissen Propaganda unterliegen die
Bildzeitung tut da einiges dazu ich sehe
immer zur Chance eine russische Panzer
ich sehe die Ukraine hat neu gewonnen
ich glaube das nicht so recht weil ich
nicht dran glauben kann dass die
russische Armee so schwach ist wie sie
dargestellt wird deswegen müssen da
Waffen hin aber ich habe mich schon sehr
gewundert wie wie hyperaktiv plötzlich
die Grünen wurden also Anton Hofreiter
habe ich in der Zeit wo ich in Berlin
gewohnt habe gesehen wir im
dreiteiler-anzug auf dem Radl durch
Berlin-Mitte gefahren ist jeder
Waffengattung mittlerweile Pazifist war
aber Pazifismus ist so lange sehr edel
bis die erste Bombe fällt und für mich
heißt der plötzlich der Panzer Toni weil
er der Vertreter derjenigen bei den
Grünen ist die das for die
Waffenlieferungen forcieren weil wir
eine Menge Menschen Menschen
vehement vertritt das heute die Grüne
Partei vertreten das hier auch Frau
Fegebank und Frau Beck fehlte sie im
Moment an der Alternative dazu
also ich glaube dass der Bundeskanzler
Scholz Recht hat von dem ich heute in
der Zeitung gelesen habe nicht
Bundeskanzler Stolz der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Mütze nicht der die
Außenministerin doch gemahnt oder
gebeten hat
nie vor lauter
kriegswaffenlieferungspropaganda nicht
die Diplomatie zu vergessen generell
brauchen wir in der Ukraine
jetzt keine Winston Churchill Lösung
sondern eine Henry Kissinger Aktion und
das könnte und müsste von Deutschland
als besonderen Verantwortungsträger
kommen
ich habe was die Grünen angeht ihre
Waffenlosigkeit nie abgenommen und was
Frau wegschafft ist die halbe Wahrheit
und die ganze Lüge die Grünen haben als
Apo Leute massiv mit der Parole Sieg im
Volkskrieg angefangen ich habe wir sind
doch fast Altersgenossen wir haben sie
doch erlebt ein bisschen Waffen für eine
caragua gesammelt haben
wie die wieder Vietnamkrieg auf der
deutschen Straßen übertragen worden ist
es ist Herr Ströbele verstorben Gott hab
ihn selig und ich mochte ihn auf eine
gewisse Art gerne aber der massiv sich
damals in diese
waffenlieferungsprogramme eingemischt
hatte
die Militanz im in der internationalen
Politik die hat sich dann gespiegelt in
der Art und Weise wie Sie sich auf
unserer Straßen aufgeführt haben also
sie hat auch immer
nein diese friedensstopp diese
friedensnummer nimmt euch keiner ab die
gab es nicht in echt noch in den 80er
Jahren ist aus Gründen der
propalästinensischen Unterstützung noch
in den 80er Jahren haben die Israelis
führenden grünen Politikern wegen der
Unterstützung von Gewalttaten der
Palästinenser die Einreise nach Israel
verweigert und insofern kehren Sie jetzt
damit mit ihren mit ihren
waffenlieferungspropaganda und
vernichtungsfantas mit Russland zu ihren
alten Wurzeln zurück
ich bin groß geworden
im Schoß der evangelischen Kirche mit
den ersten Schritten in der Ausbildung
und Vietnam war tatsächlich ja ein
großer Schock was dort den Menschen
zugefügt worden ist und das war ja nicht
nur in Deutschland so sondern das war
auch in den USA so und dieser Krieg ist
dann zum Glück ja auch viel zu spät
beendet worden
das was Herr Gauweiler beschreibt das
ist bei den Grünen einzelne gegeben hat
die für Waffen für Elstal cyber-dur
gewesen sind zum Beispiel Ströbel das
ist die haben sich auch nie als
Pazifisten bezeichnet übrigens aber der
große Teil derjenigen die 1980 und 83
gegen die Pershings auf die Straße
gegangen sind und die Grünen übrigens
immer gegen die SS-20 auch auch gegen
die russischen Atomraketen wir haben
gesagt diese atomare be ist
hochgefährlich und sie ist es ja auch
sie ist es ja auch es kann ja niemand
sind sie noch eine pazifistische Partei
heute die Grünen nein die Grünen sind
keine pazifistische Partei sie sind
übrigens das ist etwas was man in den
grünen selber auch noch mal diskutieren
muss mit dem gewaltfrei mit diesem Bein
gewaltfrei haben sie nie den Pazifismus
bezeichnet sondern sie haben sich gegen
diejenigen abgegrenzt die bei
anti-akademonstrationen gewalttätig
geworden sind diese Bewegung hat immer
gesagt wir üben keine Gewalt aus das war
die gewaltklinik das logisch für Sie
Wiener wie Frau Blatt darf ich sagen das
ist das ist das ist die glatte
Unwahrheit was wir gerade gehört haben
und dann weiter in der Runde das genaue
das genaue Gegenteil ist richtig die
Grünen haben massiv zur Gewaltaktionen
nicht mehr aufgerufen sondern massiv
daran beteiligt erzeuge Joschka Fischer
der als Straßenkämpfer in Frankfurt
ja mit verwickelt war
was heißt nicht als grüner das ist eure
Symbolfigur jetzt habe ich umsonst
massiv massiv in Gewalttaten und weil
sie dir es ist 20 Proteste angehen die
sind Angesicht sie sind angeführt worden
von dem die sind angeführt wann von dem
General Bastian der seine
Lebensgefährtin Petra Kelle erschossen
gleichzeitig wahnsinnige rückwärts
gewandt deswegen noch einmal
überhaupt nicht mehr hören ist das für
sie logisch andere sagen und noch ein
letztes Mal Frau Wagenknecht das ist
heuchlerisch
naja ich persönlich sage in der
Situation ist es natürlich
nachvollziehbar und wir als Union treten
ja auch dafür ein dass wir der Ukraine
in dieser Situation helfen und helfen
können in dieser Frage ja ich weiß nicht
ob ich jetzt verantwortlich dafür bin
wie die Grünen das begründen ich sage
wie wir dazu stehen und natürlich wissen
wir streiten aber heute einfach über die
Grünen was ich persönlich was ich
persönlich mal gedacht habe auch in
früheren Jahren wenn wir dann auch immer
gesagt haben naja wir brauchen auch
natürlich eine funktionierende
Bundeswehr wir brauchen da auch
Waffenlieferungen im Gebiete wo es
schwierig ist dann ist schnell auch der
moralisierende Zeigefinger aber nehmen
Sie das zum Beispiel Anton Hofreiter ab
so wie Waldemar hat man das gerade
geschildert hat Panzer Toni sagt
waldemar Hartmann nehmen Sie das den
Grünen ab sind die glaubwürdig in dieser
Frage jetzt für Waffenlieferung in die
Ukraine also ich halte das schon für
glaubwürdig ich glaube was ja auf
Freitag da sagt das meinte auch so der
Wechsel von einer Partei die ja für ganz
andere Dinge eingetreten ist Frieden
schaffen ohne Waffen ja das war ja nun
für viele Jahre auch tatsächlich das
Auto
aber das ist nicht nur seit der Zeit so
dass der Wechsel jetzt ist schon
bemerkenswert und der ganze Wahnsinn ja
angefangen die Rahmenbedingungen würde
ich auch jedem zugestehen dass er sich
in seiner Haltung ändert aber der
Wechsel ist schon bemerkenswert und ob
es dann glaube ich ist das wird man dann
in der Zeit auch sehen vor allen Dingen
dann aussehen wenn andere wieder
Regierungsverantwortung tragen und wie
sich dann die Grünen dar